hi mata hi martin what's going on
i loaded some ecommerce order data into
bigquery
now i want to transform that data and
create a new table that's optimized for
my business intelligence dashboard
somebody told me you might have pointers
for how to do that
yes you should check out dbt it's a
third-party tool to transform data by
simply writing select statements
it doesn't extract or load data but it
is extremely good at transforming data
that's already loaded into your
warehouse
cool will do
[Music]
hi mette thanks for your tip about dbt i
found a really nice tutorial on how to
transform data within bigquery
it does pretty much what i need it joins
a customer and an order table into a new
dashboard friendly table
i got it working on my google cloud
account can i show you
sure let's see all right um switch over
here
to this i'll
go into the jaffa shop example that i
loaded
i'm running dbt run
let's see if it runs
so there it says completed successfully
and if i go over
to my project and i
go into bigquery
and i go into my customers data set
here i have a table and
a customer table that was created by
this job i click preview
and sure enough there's my denormalist
customer data good job martin but i have
one question
how are you going to run this in the
long run i can imagine typing dbt run
every day will get old pretty quickly
also you probably want bigquery to
always have the latest data
even when you're out on vacation okay
uh well i guess i could trigger the
command on a schedule
uh from a cron job on my laptop
will then your laptop be closed when
you're on location
hmm maybe i could get a virtual machine
to run this in the cloud you could
but why keep a virtual machine running
24 7
when you only need it for a few seconds
per day
and you probably don't want to add
server maintenance to your to-do list
ugh i hate managing servers i'm not good
at it
let's go serve this instead but how
would i run a custom command line tool
from a serverless product like cloud
functions
the cloud functions runtime doesn't have
dbt installed
that's true but we have other options in
cloud run
you can create your own runtime with a
container
there's a base container image with dbt
we can start with that
that sounds great how do i set that up
open your google cloud project and i'll
show you
all right so i'm here in my project
cloud run lets you run containers
without having to maintain a server
and you only pay when your code runs
uh cool uh but i don't know much about
containers or
docker as a matter of fact i don't even
have docker installed here on my laptop
no worries we'll build the container
using cloud build
your code in cloud run is triggered by
http requests
in this case we will run the dbt command
in a shell script
in response to an http request let's
find a simple http server
that can run shell scripts go to cloud
run tutorial
and find the sample for running a shell
script in cloud run
and copy that code to your machine okay
so i'm in the quick start for build and
deploy
on cloud run scrolling down the page
here
i want to run a shell script uh
here's a shell script okay it seems like
uh there is a go
program here that can run shell scripts
so i copy that
i paste that into my machine okay i've
saved it as
invoke dot go on my machine
cool then save your dbt command in a
script file
all right i did that already i have it
script dot sh
here on my machine now let's
containerize our code
i send you a docker file for the
container image
we are relying on a base image that
includes the dbt
tool we are also copying the go http
server
along with the script file to the
container the entry point to the
container is the http server
let's build the container with cloud
build i send you the command for doing
that
all right uh you sent me uh
let's see build container so i'm running
that now
all right it finished building the
container
let's deploy the container to cloud run
that's the second command i have sent
you
all right i got it so deploy container
very good i'm running that now
all right uh the script for deploying
container uh finished running
so it says something here serving
traffic hundred percent at
url and there's a url with uh with a
strange
uh hash code in it what's this url
that's the service url when you hit that
url
the code you just uploaded runs try it
oh cool all right so i'm going to my
browser here
pasting it in and running it let's see
what happens
oh cool so i see the uh the printout
that i previously got from my dbt job in
my console i now see that in my web
browser
and uh let's see if i go over to
bigquery
and refresh here
i open my customers data set
click the customer table and let's see
there's a table there
i click preview and sure enough there's
my
uh the normalized customer table
including order dates and everything
nice great all right so
let me delete this table again
to make sure that we can recreate it
customers delete
um so i moved my dbt job from my laptop
to the cloud i can run the dbt job by
hitting a url
but i still have to manually hit that
url for my browser
the job won't run by itself when i'm on
vacation
that's right but we can fix that cloud
scheduler is a service that can trigger
an endpoint on a given schedule
let's go to a class scheduler page and
create a new job
all right i'm clicking cloud scheduler
here
uh create new job
and okay so i have a bunch of fields
here i guess for
name i'll say right like dbt
job perhaps frequency this is something
with stars and numbers what's this about
meta
so that's the frequency that the class
scheduler will will call your service
it's in chrome format so i guess in this
case we want to run it once a day
every day in the afternoon so we will
enter
something like 0 16
and start start very good i did that
and let's see time zone i wanted to be
in my time zone
i'm in the pacific u.s pacific standard
time
and i needed to fix the name here
all right so uh method the next one is
target so i can choose between http
pub sub and app engine http what should
i pick here
so in this case we want to hit a cloud
run service
which is an http endpoint so we'll
choose http
okay http it is and for url i guess i
should
paste in that url that i hit manually
before
yes that's the cloud run service url
excellent and if i remember correctly i
hit it with a get not with a post
i'm clicking create here
and uh look there's my new job
yes it's created but it's not running
yet uh we can actually test it out by
just clicking the run now button to
trigger it manually
oh cool uh okay i'm clicking run now
uh-huh very good something happened all
right so i'm going into
uh my project here in bigquery
i see the customers data set there and
there's the customers table that i
deleted before it has been recreated
let's just have a look at the preview of
that table
and yep there is my denormalized order
data
table is there everything is working but
meta i'm accessing this from an
incognito window i just hit the url here
and it just came through
can anyone access that url and run my
job
that's right it's a public service right
now
but we can make it private so only
authenticated users can access it
then we can configure class scheduler to
use a service account
to access this private service i have
written a tutorial that explains how to
do that
the link is in the description below
okay
so let's summarize what we did we
started with cloud scheduler
that hit a url on a schedule that
triggered
a cloud run job that cloudrunjob ran
a script file a shell script file which
in turn
is running a dbt command that
updates uh transforms the data in my
bigquery
data warehouse exactly
and the key point is that we run dbt
commands
without having to maintain servers and
we run it on a schedule
so that you don't need to be around to
trigger it every day
i like that i don't have to remember to
run this every day
manually now you can go back to the
beach without having to
think about service martin
[Music]
you